ich sage ihnen was gegen sie gegen
deutschland spricht es ist das sozial
leistungssystem dass die
flüchtlingsströme aus meinem land an
treibt die menschen kommen über
griechenland nicht weil sie nach
griechenland kommen wollen sondern weil
sie wissen dass sie wenn sie es nach
deutschland oder österreich oder holland
oder schweden schaffen anspruch auf
leistungen haben die ein vielfaches der
unterstützung oder später gehälter ist
die sie in griechenland bekommen wo wir
wegen des eu spardiktat nicht mal neue
sozialwohnungen für griechen haben
anerkannte flüchtlinge bekommen in
griechenland ein gleichwertiges
sozialpaket wie griechische bürger
weniger als 400 euro pro monat und es
gibt keine kostenlose unterkunft das
mögen sie unsozial finden aber wir haben
nicht mehr geld wie kann ich also eine
person davon überzeugen in griechenland
zu bleiben und 700 euro in einem
landwirtschaftlichen betrieb zu
verdienen wenn es länder in europa gibt
die der gleichen person 2000 bis 3000
euro fürs nichtstun bieten wir müssen
also in europa einen weg finden um diese
leistungen in ihren ländern zu stoppen
wenn sie den menschen die in ihr land
kommen hohe vorteile bieten wird dass
menschen anziehen das problem ist dass
sie diese menschen über griechenland
anlocken und ich möchte nicht das tor
nach europa sei
der villa das ist eine ganz klare
beschwerde an deutschland das die
sozialleistung hier zu hoch seien ist
dem so sind die sozialleistung hier zu
hoch so dass das ganz klar der pool
faktor ist und auch eine belastung für
die pole für die griechen in dem fall
also der griechische minister hat die
motivation zutreffend beschrieben das
ist so das enthebt aber griechenland
nicht von ihrer pflicht im eu recht die
sekundär migration auch zu unterbinden
in der tat ist richtig ein einheitliches
europa setzt auch einheitliche standort
im asyl- und immigrations verfahren
voraus und dazu gehört es auch dass
beispielsweise
sozialleistungen gleichmäßig bezahlt
werden das ist in der tat so richtig wir
müssen in deutschland darüber reden dass
auch anzugleichen
du hast alle rollender maßgeblich nach
deutschland und zum zweiten und zum
zweiten geht es darum die er natürlich
auch bei denjenigen die vollziehbar
ausreisepflichtig sind dann auch zu
entsprechenden kürzungen der
sozialleistungen zu kommen also solange
noch solche fälle da sind werden wir
kaum in der motivation verhindern können
dass das gros nach deutschland wollen
trotzdem noch einmal um das
klarzustellen das würde ja bedeuten dass
wenn es eine angleichung gibt dass wir
unsere sozialleistungen dann absenken
weil dass die griechen die sowieso
relativ wenig geld auf der hohen kante
liegen haben ihre sozialleistungen auf
unser niveau anheben das ist sagen wir
mal ja sehr ausgeschlossen
also wir haben natürlich
verfassungsrechtliche gesetzliche
bestimmungen auch da beißt sich die
katze in den schwanz wir haben ein
einheitliches europa aber noch nicht
angeglichen die sozialleistung das
müsste aus meiner sicht möglich sein zum
beispiel kann den tag ein teil ja auch
als sachleistungen ausbezahlt werden das
würde entsprechend auch zur reduktion
führen und gerade bei denen die
vollziehbar ausreisepflichtig sind nicht
abgeschoben werden können aus vielerlei
gründen mangelte pass ersatzpapiere
passt papiere keine kooperation der
herkunftsländer dort müsste es auch der
deutlichen kürzungen der
sozialleistungen kommen das ist richtig
herr marquardt teilen sie dass unsere
sozialleistungen sind so sind zu hoch
beziehungsweise im vergleich zu den
griechen zu hoch jetzt hört man von
ihnen sie wollen er voll weg von diesen
asylbewerberleistungen und wollen sofort
volle sozialleistungen zahlen es gibt
noch gewisse unterschiede zwischen
diesen beiden leistung sie wollen
schluss machen mit den
asylbewerberleistungen würde bedeuten es
fallen noch höhere kosten an es wird
noch attraktiver
also es ist nicht so wie der griechische
minister bei einem respekt gesagt hat
dass die flüchtlinge zwei bis
dreitausend euro im monat bekommen also
das liegt bei alleinstehenden menschen
in erstaufnahmeeinrichtung bei 328 euro
und dafür riskiert jetzt niemand über
jahre sein leben es ist in der tat aber
so dass wir eine situation haben in
europa wo man aus meiner sicht gar nicht
so stark über die sozialleistung reden
muss sondern wo man darüber reden muss
wie kann es denn sein dass diese
bürgerkriegs befürchtet nämlich dass aus
den emails trotzdem liter und 3 x naja
ist schon mein punkt bei dem also schon
gemacht der ist aber falsch gemacht denn
der punkt den ich machen will ist dass
der griechische migrationsminister da
auch davon ablenkt dass er
menschenunwürdig behandelt da gelten
keine mindeststandards in den lagern in
griechenland es werden menschen
verprügelt an der grenze und zwar
mehrfach verprügelt und natürlich wenn
man so behandelt wird dann will man dort
nicht bleiben das macht polen ja genauso
die meisten menschen die in deutschland
ankommen dem atom am körper hat eine
dauer von der caritas in
eisenhüttenstadt jetzt gesagt also wenn
man überall verprügelt wird in europa
bestreiten menschenwürde das ist die
finanziellen leistungen dieser dieser
faktor sind derzeit sozusagen der
deutschland so attraktiv macht sie sagen
es sind die unwürdigen verhältnissen in
griechenland man wird hier besser
behandelt in deutschland das ist der
faktor aber nicht die materiellen
leistungen die das geld ja ich glaube
dass es ein zusammenspiel das wäre jetzt
albern wenn ich behaupten würde die
menschen würden überhaupt nicht schauen
dass ich irgendwo ein existenzminimum
bekommen aber ich glaube sozusagen das
im zusammenhang zu sehen und auch zu
sehen dass viele menschen ja nicht
irgendwo hinkommen um sozialleistungen
zu bekommen sondern die wollen leben in
sicherheit und sie sich eine zukunft
aufbauen auch arbeiten gehen da
möglichst schnell ankommen in der neuen
gesellschaft wenn sie dann
schutzbedürftig sind und ich finde
darauf muss man sich auch ein bisschen
stärker zu konzentrieren diese
geschichte die wir jetzt seit vielen
jahren immer mal diskutieren also kommen
die leute eigentlich nur wegen der
soziale heute mein ich halte ich das
geht nicht wir zuerst um die
sozialleistung das ist nicht der faktor
für die menschen zu uns zugleich findet
ihr die alternative ist nicht die die
herr marquardt gerade auf macht denn
natürlich riskieren menschen nicht
einfach mal ihr leben und gehen auf eine
lebensgefährliche gute weil sie genau
wüssten wie jetzt in welchem land gerade
die sozialleistungen sind aber wenn sie
erst mal in europa sind ist die
sekundäre migration klar nachweisbar
dass die zum allergrößten teil dann
weiter nach deutschland geht und wir
müssen uns wenn wir eine tragfähige
lösung wollen und ich will die fdp will
die in europa mit dem fakt
auseinandersetzen dass er unsere
verwaltungsgerichte und zwar nicht nur
bezüglich griechenland auch bezüglich
italien zb urteilen man dürfe auch
dublin fällen ich drück überstellt
rückte nur um diese freiheiten so
einfach ist den griechischen
migrationsminister mich nicht um dieser
mann kann zweierlei maß misst nur die
frage ist sind die so im all zu hoch wir
müssen daran was tun und wir müssen zum
beispiel dafür sorgen dass man nicht
weiter reisen kann und dann im nächsten
start auch sozialleistungen kriegt
sondern wenn wir ernsthaften europäische
lösungen wollen dann muss bei dem start
der zuständig ist für den asylantrag
dieses menschen dann muss er auch dort
dieses asylverfahren durchführen und
kann ich in einem zweiten oder dritten
start in denen er weiterreist gegen
dieses system der europäischen asyl also
alle gesehen haben die schon in polen
gelandet sind die haben dann in
deutschland keinen anspruch auf
sozialleistungen mehr weil die sind ja
in polen gelangt er ein solches system
sollten wir schaffen tatsächlich weil
sonst können ja sonst wäre doch alle
verteilung über die wir vernünftig
verhandeln wollen in europa in der
praxis makulatur wenn man sich an den
standort gar nicht hält er für ein
zuständig ist an dem mitgliedstaat das
heißt wir brauchen standards die
realistisch sind wir werden italien und
klosters nicht unsere aufzwingen können
sie müssen aber menschenwürdig sein und
wir müssen ein system hinbekommen bei
den menschen dann in dem land bleiben
das für sie zu spendieren wir gleich
wollte